[Musique]
autant je suis conscient de
réchauffement climatique exactement
ce réchauffement voilà une idée
dites pas que c'est pas bien là encore
de la même manière vous mettez en
difficulté dans une société où on est
souvent attaqué notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux quand vous dites que je
suis climatoceptique c'est pas bien non
plus de dire des choses comme ça parce
que ce n'est pas vrai mais comme je ne
suis que tout amour et que c'est Noël je
vous pardonne qu'est-ce qu'il y a
décroche pas moi
non j'ai failli me vautrer en marchant
lui aussi a passé une belle matinée le
ministre de la Santé François Brown
votre invité ce matin à Pauline c'est
François Brown le ministre de la Santé
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est qui
vient dans ce studio il n'a pas de
masque oh le nul il vit en studio il
porte pas de masse et ce n'était qu'une
mise en bouche car ce matin sur BFM
c'était petit déj continental pour le
ministre un café croissant écoute
[Musique]
[Rires]
des ministres nucléaires tous masqués
lors des questions au gouvernement le
président lui-même qu'il affiche
ostensiblement hier lors d'un
déplacement l'exécutif et serait-il de
faire passer un message il semble que
oui j'ai mis le masque non pas parce que
je vous rassure je serais malade mais
je suis les préconisations de mon
ministre de la Santé et face à la
remontée de l'épidémie et de la
conjonction
parce que c'est bien de faire de la
pédagogie parce qu'on n'a pas envie de
revenir vers les obligations
généralisées forcément et donc c'est
aussi une manière de reprendre des
habitudes basées sur le volontariat
l'esprit de responsabilité voilà
chaque jour on pouvait dire de lui
changer la vie j'ai dû dans tes mémoires
que quand tu étais sur le bateau de
Tabarly tu n'étais pas payé mais il
avait un sous on n'est pas d'argent non
pas d'argent que j'avais compris que
mieux vaut être pauvre avec des très
bons que riches et des cons donc c'est
vachement bien
le dernier étage est avant vous avez
plus d'argent que nous vous allez
pouvoir le rester
alors non mais regarde ils vont très
cher regardez qui crie misère 45
émissions par mois sur le service public
[Rires]
je sais pas ce qui se passe chez moi
mais apparemment il faut que je
recontacte de toute urgence ah retard de
paiement bah oui ma Choups de 33 jours
ouh là à mon avis j'ai pétrie c'était
chez moi
on a des pénalités j'étais l'élu de
Véronique Sanson une femme aimée par
plein de gens j'étais très fier d'être
le mari de Véronique Sanson et par
contre j'adorais faire des câlins à Véro
mais j'étais avec avec son enfant je les
mets aussi pour ça célébrité et je
trouve que c'est malhonnête de dire
qu'on n'aime pas quelqu'un parce qu'il
est célèbre
je vous aime
normal
de quoi de recevoir besoin d'être
reconnu regardé par les autres ce qui
est tout à fait normal je vous disais
toujours que si on a envie d'être acteur
on a d'abord envie d'être regardé par
les autres si ça ne reste que ça ça n'a
aucun intérêt mais ça commence par ça et
c'est normal si je les appelle et je
leur dis j'étais à la star ça marche
allô papa dit à maman de payer mon
électricité ça fait 33 jours que j'ai
pas payé mon électricité moi c'est le
truc qui me font stresser ça attendez ne
vous énervez pas monsieur
vous n'avez rien à cacher voilà il y a
aucune raison vous êtes quelqu'un
d'honnête de professionnel donc au
contraire je vous fais de la bulle merde
il a quand même un tribunal s'Il veut Il
y a pas de souci vous a donné 15000 €
16000 et aujourd'hui c'est un truc mais
vous plaisantez ou quoi les Japonais
sont en manque d'affection et une
entreprise l'a bien compris en inventant
le premier robot de compagnie
son nom le vote un robot
émotionnellement intelligent de 3 kg qui
ressemble à une peluche son seul but
vous apporter de l'amour et de
l'affection grâce à son système de
reconnaissance faciale il reconnaît son
propriétaire et s'adapte aux expressions
de ses émotions s'il vous sentent il
viendra alors ce bleu tir contre vous
pour un câlin réconfortant calmons-nous
je vais lui demander
je suis né comme ça monsieur je suis
désolé j'essaie de m'améliorer mais
c'est de pire en pire je suis un très
gros con maintenant mais monsieur
blanchery avait la raccroché ah bah là
vous êtes tombé très fort on arrive
il a eu blanche chérie comme les autres
alors là je ne vous cache pas que le
dossier va être compliqué parce que bon
me faire traiter le gros con j'ai envie
de vous dire c'est un peu mon quotidien
il interagit réellement avec vous en
pression les marques d'affection en
rigolant quand on le chatouille et on
s'endormant lorsqu'il est bercé alors si
vous en voulez un à la maison sachez
qu'il vous en coûtera tout de même 3000
€. moi j'ai une phrase envoyée par Orson
ou Orson je sais pas de Paris une phrase
de John Lennon qui dit à l'école quand
on va me demander d'écrire ce que je
voulais être plus tard j'ai répondu
heureux ils m'ont dit que je n'avais pas
compris la question je leur ai dit qu'il
n'avait pas compris la vie